Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
In this piece of work, you'll see wondrous
little sequences of animations where a virtual
character is asked to write on a whiteboard,
move boxes, and perform different kinds of
sitting behaviors.
The emphasis is on synthesizing believable
footstep patterns for this character.
This sounds a bit mundane, but we'll quickly
realize that the combination and blending
of different footstep styles is absolutely
essential for a realistic animation of these
tasks.
Beyond simple locomotion (walking if you will),
for instance, sidestepping, using toe and
heel pivots, or partial turns and steps every
now and then are essential in obtaining a
proper posture for a number of different tasks.
A rich vocabulary of these movement types
and proper transitions between them lead to
really amazing animation sequences that you
can see in the video.
For instance, one of the most heinous examples
of the lack of animating proper locomotion
we can witness in older computer games, and
sometimes even today, is when a character
is writing on a whiteboard, who suddenly runs
out of space, turns away from it, walks a bit,
turns back towards the whiteboard and continues
writing there.
Even if we have impeccable looking photorealistically
rendered characters, such robotic behaviors
really ruin the immersion.
In reality, a simple sidestepping would do
the job, and this is exactly what the algorithm
tells the character to perform.
Very simple and smooth.
This technique works by decomposing a given
task to several subtasks, like starting to
sit on a box, or getting up, and choosing
the appropriate footstep types and transitions
for them.
One can also mark different tasks as being
low or high-effort that are marked with green
and blue.
A low effort task could mean fixing a minor
error on the whiteboard nearby without moving
there, and a high effort task that we see
marked with blue would be continuing our writing
on a different part of the whiteboard.
For these tasks, the footsteps are planned
accordingly.
Really cool.
This piece of work is a fine example of the
depth and complexity of computer graphics
and animation research, and how even the slightest
failure in capturing fine scale details is
enough to break the immersion of reality.
It is also really amazing that we have so
many people who are interested in watching
these videos about research, and quite a few
of you decided to also support us on Patreon.
I feel really privileged to have such amazing
supporters like you Fellow Scholars.
As always, I kindly thank you for this at
the end of these videos, so here goes...
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!